en paraphant cette convention avec
orange didier laguerre le maire de la
ville de fort-de-france opte pour un
déploiement de la culture numérique en
direction de ses administrés de nouveaux
services urbains destinés à valoriser la
performance opérationnelle la cité
pouilles à l'aise mais aussi plus
d'interaction avec les citoyens dans le
court terme il sera possible d'optimiser
la vitesse des véhicules en période de
pointe de connaître les places de
stationnement qui sont libres le
réaliser les économies d'échelle mais
surtout d'améliorer le cadre de vie et
la sécurité des habitants
un champ d'activité très large allant de
la cohésion sociale à l'accompagnement
de la population à la prise de décision
nous avons la possibilité de participer
pleinement à l'économie du numérique qui
va être un des piliers de l'économie du
21e siècle est mon
ambition c'est de faire en sorte fort de
france traîne sa part il montre montre
le chemin montre la voie il s'est
construit avec orange va nous permettre
d'expérimenter par exemple dans les flux
de déplacement des dix utilisateurs de
la ville pour préparer pour anticiper
les aménagements nécessaires mais elle
va aussi nous permettre par exemple de
travailler sur le vote dématérialisée
pour améliorer nos processus de
concertation avec la population lors des
projets qui sont portés par la ville ou
par l'est les recettes de quartier c'est
toute une réflexion d'avenir qui est
menée par un catalogue des aides à la
décision avec des indicateurs permettant
de mesurer d'analyser les flux de
population mais aussi de prendre des
décisions sur les aménagements futurs
une maison digital verra le jour en juin
2018 pour les femmes sans qualification
et sans emploi
les enfants des écoles et collèges
seront aussi intégrés dans ce projet
d'aménagement numérique de la ville je
pense qu'on s'y inscrire complètement
c'est de se projeter sur permettre aux
citoyens de voter massivement sur des
projets d'analysé les flux tels que
l'opération fut vision peut le faire
pour essayer d'appréhender finalement
les leviers sur le tourisme
l'évolution urbaine je pense qu'on s'est
complètement dans une ville du futur
une smart cities comme on les appelle
fort de france est la première ville
d'outre-mer et la troisième de france
apprennent le vert et saint quentin a
enclenché une dynamique digital pour une
nouvelle relation avec ses administrés
et surtout anticiper les besoins de le
maire